poser des questions c'est lp voyant
question j'adore c'est que ça je peux
faire ça le betouch mental si tu as
d'autres questions tu poses de pita leur
jeu donc on va faire du cinéma
alors attention tu nous diras si c'est
vrai borloo sera normalement elle nous
l'a fait contre s'il y avait du cinéma
bhattarai on va la recevoir
si toi que tu crois que tu m'aimes plus
tôt mais si oui c'est particulier de ma
passion à l'eic et surtout bonjour je
m'appelle françoise la semaine dernière
j'ai appris que matthieu delormeau
allait présenter move 2
je trouve ça super mais chez un peu
inquiète
est il nécessaire d'avoir vu le 1 pour
comprendre la suite
elles sont trois soeurs françoise et les
pages et cette angoisse pas beaucoup
téléspectateurs car c'est vrai qu'à la
fin de wouf 1 a vu un gros suspense
citobi allait réussir à monter sur la
balançoire on serait sûr des jeux pas si
ce prototype se pare d'un chat pas de
danse à m'assister de mathieu donc vous
rassure a priori ça sera pas une suite
d'un reboot 1 les deux histoires seront
indépendantes avec un nouveau casting de
l'andorre salle en poils en tout cas
c'est vrai à mathieu la semaine dernière
il a été gâté pour son anniversaire
harry
car ce que vous savez pas c'est qu'il
n'a pas reçu que ce cadeau non abbassi
par ce coup alors je vous racontais à
segré il est né cinq je suis né le 6 et
13 ans tim ans il s'appelle m'a appelé
mardi 6 pour me demander ce que je
voulais qu'elle m'offre même me
l'acheter même dit que tu t'achètes est
à prévoir en bourse
bon j'ai été très touché mais j'ai
refusé évidemment observe j'étais gêné à
vous ne savez pas par contre c'est qu'il
avait fait la même proposition à
matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
lacoste
moi j'aurais
mais s'attendent à coder adorable et
voyons ce qu'il a fait ou ce qu'il n'a
pas fait part en part alors ça vocales
annonce à kirumba toits des lycées jean
luc continuer mais après chaque émission
choix qui lui taxer aussi un peu
d'argent de poche
alors regardons la vision d'ailleurs
j'étais chez moi mardi j'ai appris que
j'avais gagné un prime est un cadeau de
camille alors j'ai toujours pas vu ni
l'un ni l'autre ado que vous m'offrez ce
que vous m'aviez déjà offert avant oui
d'accord c'est très bon hockey
est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres après
encore ok donc je n'ai pas de cadeaux
haut placé de la foire il y en a plein
mais du coup parce que le cas de camille
je n'aime pas ce qu'ils avaient dans la
petite boîte de camille heureusement que
j'allais aof